Some of my supplements say to take out of the empty stomach like pectusol capsules and others like black sand blood
Room say to take with food
So I'll stop right there first. I typically don't have people take pectusol on an empty stomach
I know that's recommended. I just know that sometimes some things you just can't
So um, I typically have people put pectusol in their drink
It's hard to work all that in taking so many things
All important is it to follow instructions closely. I think the most important thing to take out of empty stomach is number one homeopaths
Uh, so if you're taking a homeopath you can't take that with food you can't
You know, you have to take that least 15 minutes away from brushing your teeth and or eating food
And number two is um binders
So if you're taking binders should typically take that in the afternoon and typically take that out of
Not a relatively empty stomach
But quite honestly I have taken binders after I eat I've taken you know
Is it I'm just saying the best practice. So that's the best practice um
Um, but that's the two most important things